>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Betsy Peterson: Hello, everyone.
I'm Betsy Peterson, director of
the American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress
and I want to welcome you
to the latest presentation in the
Benjamin Botkin Lecture Series.
The Botkin series is an opportunity
for the American Folklife Center
to present the very best research
from leading scholars in folklore,
ethnomusicology, world
history, and cultural heritage.
It also allows us to
enhance our collections.
And by that, what I mean is each
of these lectures are videotaped
and they become a part
of our archive.
They also are eventually
posted in the library's website
and made available to Internet
patrons throughout the world
and are preserved for
future generations.
So with all of that
description, please let me ask
if you have any electronic
devices turned
on at this point, please
turn them off.
We would greatly appreciate it.
And while you're doing that,
let me tell you a little
bit about today's lecture.
Today, I have the owner honor
of introducing the distinguished
scholar Gearóid Ó hAllmhuráin.
Professor Ó hAllmhuráin is
an award-winning Irish musician
ethnomusicologist and
cultural historian.
He is formerly the Jefferson
Smurfit Professor of Irish studies
and Professor of Music at the
University of Missouri in St. Louis.
And he currently holds the
bilingual Johnson chair
in Québec & Canadian Irish studies
at Concordia University in Montréal.
A native of County Clare, he has
performed, broadcast, adjudicated,
and lectured on Irish music
throughout Europe and North America.
He holds degrees from
University College Cork,
Queens University Belfast
and the Sorbonne.
His musical career is
as distinguished as
his academic career.
A formal member of the
Kilfenora Ceili Band,
he is a five-time all-Ireland
champion musician on uilleann pipes,
concertina, and ceili band.
And he is a fourth-generation
Clare concertina player.
He's also produced numerous
CDs, documentary films,
and radio programs, and
is a frequent commentator
on Irish music and culture.
He is also the author of a pocket
history of Irish traditional music,
which has just been
re-released as a short history
of Irish traditional music as
well as writing numerous chapters
and articles on Irish
music and culture.
His widely acclaimed book,
Flowing Tides: History and Memory
in an Irish Soundscape,
was published by Oxford
University press in 2016.
Both books are being
offered for sale today
by the LOC bookshop
just right outside.
And Professor Ó hAllmhuráin
will be taking part
in a book signing immediately
following his talk.
So again, thank you for coming
today, and please join me
in welcoming Profewssor Ó
hAllmhuráin for his talk
on Flowing Tides: Musical Memory,
History, and Global Culture
in County Clare, Ireland.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Gearóid Ó hAllmhuráin:
Thank you so much.
[ Speaking Irish ]
Good afternoon, and welcome.
I should like to say at the
onset that it's a singular honor
to be invited to give a
Benjamin Botkin lecture
by the American Folklife Center,
and to be given an opportunity
to present that lecture here in
the historic Library of Congress.
Before commencing, I would like to
start by thanking Betsy Peterson
for that wonderful,
warm introduction.
It's a pleasure to cross the
Canadian border and travel
down the historic East Coast
to this historic center.
I know I'm in the company
of Beethoven
and a whole lot of
other musical greats.
Before commencing, I would also
like to extend my sincerest thanks
to the directors, librarians
and staff
of both the American Folklife Center
and also the Library of Congress
for making this opportunity
possible.
And while I'm thanking
people, I would especially
like to think Kia [phonetic],
John [assumed spelling],
Mike [assumed spelling],
Grant [assumed spelling],
and all of the IT team
for working with me
so diligently for the last hour.
I'd also like to thank the bookshop
people for selling the books.
They are offered today at a
discount, so I would be more
than honored to go
home with all of you.
[ Laughter ]
I first read about the Library
of Congress as a child growing
up in a small town in
the west of Ireland
where our own small library
was our center of cultural
and intellectual engagement.
And I remember being so impressed
by the vision of James Madison,
John Adams, and Thomas
Jefferson that led to the birth
and the early development
of the Library of Congress.
As a child, I remember being
extremely envious of the number
of books housed here --
almost 24 million, I believe,
at the present time, and 164
million different items --
and thinking as a child how
lucky Americans were to have
such a Promethean storehouse
at their disposal.
Walking in here this morning, I
was again struck by that same sense
of wonder, but this
time, it was for real.
Indeed, there is an awesome sense
of pride and reassurance in knowing
that the vision of these Founding
Fathers continues to resonate
in this place, particularly at
this difficult time in our history
when science and intellectual
culture are being denigrated
by political expediency.
My presentation today, however,
takes us beyond the world of books
and the world of text
into the world of sound.
To another time and another place
on the western fringe of Europe,
where culture and politics
have also clashed,
leaving in their wake a
soundscape that has endured
and thrived both locally
and globally.
Ireland, as many of you
know, is a natural haven
on the Atlantic seaways
that link Nordic Europe
with the Mediterranean Sea.
For 8,000 years, it has experienced
cultural and economic contact
with people and civilizations
along this oceanic fringe from Cork
to Compostela, from
Limerick to Narvik.
These exchanges brought priests,
traders, migrants and settlers
to Ireland over the centuries.
From Mesolithic hunters who crossed
the land bridge from Scotland
to Ireland to the Eastern European's
who serviced the recent
Celtic Tiger economy,
each wave of newcomers brought
artistic and material goods,
languages, music and folkways
that mingled and merged
to form Ireland's vibrant
mosaic of cultures.
Guarding Ireland's main
river archery, the Shannon,
Clare separates the barren
wilderness of the western province
of Connacht from the rich farmlands
of Munster in the south of Ireland.
Prolonged periods of geological
time conspired to surround Clare
on three sides by water and
insulated from its neighbors.
Its only land access is through
the mountains of Slieve Aughty
or across the [inaudible] of
the Burren where according
to one Cromwellian general, there
was not enough wood to hang a man,
enough water to drown a man,
or enough dirt to bury a man.
[ Laughter ]
This is what the Burren
looks like today,
as it did when the
Cromwellian cynic visited.
Indeed, human history in the
Burren predates the Cromwellians
by 6,000 years.
Its first Neolithic farmers
arrived about 4000 BC.
And since then, human traffic in and
out of Clare has continued unabated.
Its 7,000 archaeological sites
contain Bronze Age tombs,
Iron Age forts -- like this one
-- and early Christian churches.
Clare also contains the
remains of Viking, Norman,
and [inaudible] settlers.
This is a well-known landmark in
County Clare that I'm sure many
of you are familiar with,
Bunratty Castle, which was built
by the Norman Richard the Clare.
Landlord estates, garrison
towns, chapel villages
and railroads reshaped the geography
of Clare in more recent times,
as did famine, eviction,
and immigration.
From a land perspective, Clare is
a remote, liminal place in the west
of Ireland to where the
Celts supposedly retreated
in the centuries before
the birth of Christ
after fighting a long
rearguard action
from the Alps to the Atlantic.
Creative writers and social
scientists have been intrigued
by this liminality.
In literary and socio-analytical
text,
Clare and its hinterlands are
designated sanctuaries of tradition
and authenticity, not to
mention back orders of madness,
repression, and social enemy.
A maritime compass, however,
presents a very different
perspective of this region.
Situated at the mouth of the
Shannon, Clare was in the slipstream
of ocean trade and migration
since early Christian times.
The cults of its early
Christian saints, for example,
can be found in Scotland,
Wales, Cornwall, and Brittany.
In the wake of the voyages of
discovery, Ireland, which was once
on the edge of the known world
now found itself near the center
of the New World.
During this extended age of
sale, coastal communities
on Clare's Erris Peninsula provided
river pilots for toll ships going
up the river Shannon to Limerick,
which was a last port of call
for fleets crossing
the North Atlantic.
Before the arrival of railroads
in the mid-19th century,
a network of satellite ports
dotted Clare's fractal coast
from Lough Derg on the Shannon to
Lukead [phonetic] on the Atlantic
and North towards Galway Bay.
Like this Port of Kilrush, which is
on the mouth of the river Shannon,
they all shared some sense
of clans' local engagement
with the outside world.
[Inaudible] culture
currents reached Clare
from rather unlikely destinations
in the past two millennia.
Coptic stonework, for example,
similar to carvings found
in the lower reaches
of the river Nile,
survives in early Christian
churches in the Burren
in the Aran islands,
it's geological annex.
Here, for example, you
see one of these crosses
in the village of Kilfenora.
And I'd like to direct
your attention
to the second panel
beneath the bishop.
And if you look at the figure on
the right-hand side of the screen,
you will notice the flat,
Coptic Egyptian cross.
This is a rare example of
stone masonry that traveled
from the lower reaches of the
Nile across the Mediterranean,
out through the point of Gibraltar
and around Spain, traveling north
into the western part of Ireland
where these stonemasons
created Coptic artifacts.
During the 12th and 13th centuries,
avant-garde European scholasticism
found eager patrons in Clare
when the old Gaelic world synergized
by a new European age of faith.
Here, for example, is the
Franciscan Friary in Ennis
in County Clare dating from the
mid-13th century, and again evidence
of European migration
to the west of Ireland.
The arrival of mendicant orders,
particularly the Augustinians,
the Franciscans, the Dominicans,
changed Irish Christianity
and linking it with
a new renaissance
of European Christianity.
Outward-bound currents,
too, were impressive.
Clare [inaudible] families sent
their offspring to University
in Prague, Leuven, and
Paris during the Penal Era
when its military exiles
fought imperial wars
and explored New World colonies
from new Newfoundland to Brazil.
Nowhere is the imprint of global
culture flows more pronounced,
however, then in Clare's
traditional soundscape.
That has been a site
of cultural convergence
and coalescence for centuries.
Music, irrespective of genre,
is a nomadic art whose
journeys are frequently lost
in what French historian
Jacques Le Goff called the
"indefinable residue of
historical analyses."
The transcultural odyssey of the
Arabic guitar, the African banjo,
and European Baroque dancing all
bear witness to this phenomenon.
In contrast to the architects
of the Celtic twilight
in the late 19th century who saw
the west of Ireland as a place
of timeless, romantic authenticity,
Clare musicians have a long history
of moving beyond the
injunctions of the past.
By the end of the 18th
century, the Italian violin --
which we see here in
the case beside us --
had reached Clare and was
notarized and nativized
as the Irish fiddle,
[speaking Gaelic].
Baroque flutes and fifes
were also nativized.
In the half-century
after the great famine,
the region welcomed
German concertinas --
which you'll hear at the
end of this performance --
Sicilian coral societies and British
and German style brass bands,
American Victrolas in
jazz, Italian accordions,
and Balkan bouzoukis all
arrived during the next century,
ferried in by trains,
planes, and automobiles.
Clare's bricolage of Irish tunes
today contains Scottish reels,
French galops, Bavarian marches,
and North Hungarian horn pipes,
while its set dancers
trace their ancestry
to the choreographers
of [inaudible] France.
Despite their so-called geographic
isolation on the outer edge
of Europe, Clare music makers
have released an impressive corpus
of tunes and songs into the
transcultural tide of world music.
I've no doubt that many of you
are familiar with these figures.
Master performers like Martin
Hayes, Michael Tubridy,
and Sharon Shannon are not just
local carriers of tradition.
These are the global
faces of Clare today.
Similarly, the Kilfenora Ceili Band,
the oldest dance band in Ireland,
performs Clare's repertoire
in symphony halls
and folk festivals across the globe.
In the market speak of Irish
cultural tourism, Clare,
for the music, is a
ubiquitous calling card
that beckons tourists west
from Dublin to the festivals
and singing pubs of Clare.
Every summer, its towns and
villages become makeshift academies
of tradition, none more so than
Milltown Malbay and Doolin,
Ireland's mecca of traditional
music, known to music pilgrims
and aficionados from Jura to
Japan, from the Austrian Alps
to the Pampas of Argentina.
Today, traditional music
in Clare no longer lives
in little thatched cottages in
isolated places, nor does it travel
by donkey and cart along
lonesome country roads.
It is, in fact, a polyverse of
music communities whose voices are
as vibrant in the music pubs of New
York, Washington, D.C., Montréal,
Chicago, and San Francisco
as they are
in the dance halls of
Kilfenora and Tulla.
Focusing on the interplay
between history and memory,
which are not synonymous, by the
way, my book Flowing Tides --
which is available today -- examines
the impact of global cultural flows
on Clare's so-called isolated
soundscape from the Napoleonic wars
to the Celtic Tiger boom in the
period from 1995 until 2005.
It focuses ostensibly on musical
roots but also musical routes,
both in Clare and beyond,
to a century of austere
British colonialism
and an equally strained
century of post-colonialism,
both of which exposed the region
to intense musical traffic.
Allow me to take you
through very briefly some
of the key musical moments and what
they tell us about the local as well
as the global music
history of the region.
Several key political and
economic events sourced
in Clare during the 19th century
and that were felt
throughout the British Empire
and among Irish diasporic
communities throughout the world are
centered and located and
articulated initially
in Clare before spreading outwards
throughout the island of Ireland
and elsewhere throughout
the British Empire.
For example, the election of
Catholic lawyer Daniel O'Connell
to the British Parliament for
Clare in 1828 and the passing
of Catholic emancipation a year
later changed the lives of millions
of Catholics not just in Ireland
but throughout the British Empire.
Although the Penal Laws,
which delight denied civil
and religious rights to Catholics,
were now officially revoked,
the long-term impact of
rapid population growth
and unsustainable economic practices
in Ireland proved ultimately
far more catastrophic.
This was evident in Clare
in the decades following
the Napoleonic wars.
But its population
peaked as never before.
Remember today the population
of Ireland is approximately
4 million people.
In 1821, the population of
County Clare was 208,000.
But it grew to 286,000 on the eve
of the Great Famine,
which began in 1845.
Clare, however, was
decimated by this catastrophe.
And I want to show you some images
that speak to that catastrophe.
Unlike other famines and
particularly modern famines,
the Great Irish Famine
-- which is was one
of many famines throughout the
17th and 18th century and indeed
into the latter years
of the 19th century --
the Great Famine was
not a pictorial famine.
There were no photojournalists
like Steve Winick [phonetic] --
[ Laughter ]
-- or any other major
photographic figure.
The people who chronicled
the Great Irish Famine were
government statisticians.
Eventually, the London Illustrated
News sent illustrators to Ireland
to document the famine, and here
we have an example of their work.
This is a deserted village in the
Erris Peninsula in Southwest Clare,
which was not simply deserted
by famine but was evicted
by the local landlord for --
excuse me -- nonpayment of rent.
What's interesting is that if
you travel throughout the west
of Ireland you'll see many examples
of village communities completely
abandoned leaving nothing
in their wake except the
foundations of their houses.
Here is another example perhaps
if I can use the expression,
the poster child of the Great
Irish Famine, Brigit O'Donnell
and her children photographed
or drawn so to speak in 1849
by the illustrator from the
London Illustrated News.
The area of Clare and particularly
Southwest Clare topped the national
grid in famine deaths and evictions.
By 1851, its population
had fallen to 212,000.
A century later, less than
100,000 people lived in Clare.
By now, its voluntary exiles were
dispersed throughout the New World
in Canada, the United
States, Argentina, Australia,
New Zealand, and South Africa.
An estimated 400,000 people left
Clare in the past two centuries.
People of Clare extraction today
who live overseas outnumber those
who live in Clare by a
ratio of three to one.
All of these events,
from the excitement
of Napoleon Bonaparte's
battles and campaigns
to Daniel O'Connell's electoral
victories, to the human tragedy
of famine and diastral all
found a voice and a sonic memory
in the music, song, and
dance of County Clare.
The long campaign to remove Ireland
from the British Empire
had a critical impact
on the lives of Clare people.
From the Fenian movement -- which
you are very familiar with here
in the United States -- and the
land war to the plan of campaign
and the War of Independence.
But this particular
photograph is interesting.
Is a photograph from the
land war in County Clare.
And remember within a 30-year
window, now we have photojournalism.
Now we're familiar with
the sight and sounds
of cameras chronicling political
events, unlike the experience
of the Great Famine which
was not a photographic event.
And again, we're still
singing songs and ballads
about the land war in County Clare.
Ninety years after
electing Daniel O'Connell,
Clare elected the American-born
Eamon de Valera to Parliament
on a Sinn Fein ticket in 1917.
Born in New York City of an Irish
mother and a Spanish father,
Eamon de Valera was a daunting
and enigmatic political figure.
He dominated Irish life for most
of the 20th century as a national
and international statesman
and an architect
of social and cultural change.
All of these symbolic events and
characters are remembered as much
in music and song as
they are textual history.
Feigning separatism, and
19th-century politics are still sung
about today in Clare and among
Clare exilic communities.
Likewise, the first and
second temperance movements,
public processions led by
marching bands were popular rituals
of this anti-drink crusade.
Fife and drum bands formed to rally
the faithful and to route the evil
of drink in rural and urban Ireland.
Imagine that.
These drum bands were
formed initially
to perform at religious events.
But eventually they began to
arouse less devout congregations
of Irish hurling matches
and football matches,
at land league rallies and trade
union meetings, eventually morphing
into brass and reed bands.
As funds improved, these ensembles
also spread musical literacy.
Like this particular brass and reed
band from Kilfenora in County Clare.
And this band was a very active
musical ensemble until the Irish War
of Independence when the blackened
towns, destroyed their instruments,
in an act of social
and cultural reprisal.
Some were trained by
British Army band masters
who had sufficient peace time on
their hands between the Crimean
and the Second Boer War to make
a real artistic contribution
to her majesty's subjects.
New instruments were also
introduced during this period,
in particular the Anglo-German
concertino --
which you'll hear in
a few moments --
which became a sonic
insignia in Clare
that brought musical
liberation, particularly to women
in a male-dominated world.
Cultural nationalism
designed, brokered,
and delivered by the Gaelic league
was a potent mobilizing agent
in late 19th century Ireland,
especially its rhetoric
of linguistic pride,
grassroots activism,
and competitive music making
that spread systemically
from metropolitan areas like
Dublin, Cork and Limerick
out into the rural
peripheries of Ireland.
This ideoscape reached its apogee
in Clare and in other parts
of the country with the
Rebellion of 1916 and the War
of Independence that
followed in 1919.
Caught in a vortex of chaos
and terror, musicians, too,
fell victim to the
atrocities of war.
Especially the Black
and Tans which were
who were irregular British
troops sent to Ireland
to reinforce the Royal
Irish Constabulary police.
During these turbulent times,
house dances were rated,
instruments were destroyed --
as in the case of this band --
and musicians were
forced to immigrate
to escape political violence.
In the wake of the Anglo-Irish
Treaty and Civil War,
the fledgling Irish Free
State proved rather powerless
to hold back the rising tide of
the roaring '20s from America.
That flowed without end,
it seemed, into Ireland,
particularly in the form of
jazz and its attendant sins.
[ Laughter ]
Here is an example of an Irish
jazz band, which came to prominence
in the 1920s and '30s, taking
their cues from similar kinds
of jazz bands that were active
throughout the United States.
Ireland's moral response to jazz was
to pass a draconian Dance Halls Act
in 1935 which radically altered
the musical life of the nation.
By the time World War
II began in 1939
and the Irish Free State
declared itself neutral,
Ireland's audiences had already
developed a taste for Hollywood
and indeed modern as
well as ceili dancing.
Now you will notice that in both of
these prints, this is a ceili band
from County Clare an early
example of a ceili ensemble.
But you'll notice that the
fiddle player just to the right
of the piano is, in
fact, the banjo player
at the center of the jazz band.
So they're going back and
forth between two traditions.
The countryside in
Clare and in other areas
of Ireland was now dotted with
small cinemas and dance halls.
Most of them managed by the
priest, the Catholic priest,
who brokered moral
agendas, vetted movies,
formed ceili bands,
and paid the musicians.
If the Emergency -- which
was the official title
for the World War II
period in Ireland.
Ireland, because it was neutral,
never referred to it publicly
at least in the press the war.
It was always referred to by
the rather euphemistic term
in our Irish parlance
as The Emergency,
which lasted between 1939 and 1945.
So the Emergency, which
was the official term,
seamed the country off
from the outside world.
And indeed, the depression
that followed failed
to stem the tide of freeing exiles.
This flight of people sparked a
crisis that entered the psyche
of the nation as the hungry '40s.
Now I'd like to show
you a photograph taken
by the famous American
photographer Dorothea Lange,
who most of you Americans will know
for her work chronicling the Great
Depression and the internment
of Japanese communities, etc.,
etc. And these two ladies were
photographed in County Clare
in the fall of 1954,
and they're just
about to leave Ireland for America.
The immigration of young women,
particularly from rural areas,
is very significant
because for the most part,
women did not inherit land.
And so they became the
diasporic members of the family,
as in the case of these two women
the O'Hallaren [phonetic] sisters
from Mount Callan in County Clare.
These dull, sepia-toned
years saw hundreds
of Clare musicians fall victim to
anti-jazz crusades, priestly purges,
and indeed forced exile to
quote/unquote heathen England --
[ Laughter ]
-- and America.
If Clare was on the periphery
of Irish economic life
in the early decades of Irish
independence, that isolation came
to an end on the 24th of October
1945 when Captain Charles Blair --
who most of you will know is the
husband of actress Marine O'Hara --
piles at the first
commercial flight from New York
to Shannon in a four engine DC-4.
For the next four decades,
Shannon County Clare,
the most westerly international
Airport in Europe --
although I suppose the
Portuguese would dispute that --
was a gateway for traffic
crossing the Atlantic.
It also became the world's
first duty-free zone and a hub
of international industrial
development,
all of which changed perceived
notions of centers of peripheries
in Clare and its west
of Ireland hinterland.
From now on, America had
moved closer to the social
and cultural life of the region.
As American aircrews were ferried
back and forth to local hotels
to rest between flights and
indeed relatives took vacations
to the Old Country.
In the 1960s, Shannon was
Clare's horn of plenty,
a site of paid factory work,
a place where material progress
was possible close to home
without the burden of immigration.
And indeed, if industrialization
lifted the region
out of agrarian dependency,
it did not make it
impervious to economic change.
In the past half-century,
Shannon has experienced good
and bad economic times, the latter
which brought prolonged periods
of unemployment and immigration.
Ennis, Clare's County town,
followed a similar although less
intensive trajectory.
Traditionally a farmers' town that
hosted historic fairs and markets,
Ennis acquired light industry
after Irish independence.
And attempting to follow Shannon's
lead it expanded its industrial base
in the 1960s.
However, it really became an
international town in the 1990s
when it became Ireland's
first Information Age town,
a town in which every home
was connected to the Internet
and every child became
computer literate.
Clare's cultural life also
responded to these postwar changes.
Brokered by Northern
piper Sean Reid --
who you see here in the back
row second from the right --
Reid and his cohorts
at [speaking Irish]
which is Ireland's
music Association --
you also have a branch of that
organization here in the area
of Washington, D.C. Baltimore.
And I should remind
you that [inaudible]
in Bethesda is hosting its
annual Mad Week next week,
which is music and dance week.
And please take home some
information from outside.
And if you're free, it's
a wonderful way to engage
in what we call some wonderfully
constructive musical enjoyment
and laziness.
All constructive, of course.
But back to Clare.
In 1954 [speaking Irish]
came together in County Clare
and they campaigned to bring
the All-Ireland Flack Hill Music
Festival to the region.
This is the World's
Fair of Irish music.
And indeed, they made
that happen in 1956.
Now, it will convene for the
fourth time in Ennis next month.
So if you're in Ireland
between August 14th to 21st,
you should not miss this event.
Now Reid was a very
interesting gentleman.
He was what I describe
as a Renaissance man,
interested in classical music,
jazz, philosophy, and athletics.
He came to County Clare to work
as a civil engineer in the 1930s
and he broke all the rules
of social engagement.
He did not stay and associate
with members of his own class.
He sought out the plebs, the people
who played traditional music,
sang songs, and engaged
in traditional dancing,
which was not kosher among bourgeois
society in Ireland in the 1940s.
So Reid stepped away from that
bourgeois small-town world
and became a cultural
revolutionary in every sense.
He campaigned vigorously to bring
the All-Ireland Music Festival
to the region and succeeded.
Now this new forum attracted musical
exiles from Britain and America,
and it marked a turning point
when traditional musicians
for the first time
claimed urban space.
This kind of music was a
traditional rural form of music
that you would not usually find
in metropolitan Dublin
or Limerick or Cork.
And finally, with the arrival of
the music festival, the feile ceoil,
people came to perform
music in urban spaces.
A model of civic engagement,
tourism, and business enterprise,
the 1956 festival in Ennis was also
a site of visceral public discourse
on Irish musical authenticity.
Not least the issue of whether
set dancing was actually Irish.
Was it authentic?
Most people didn't think so.
In fact, people saw it
as a foreign abomination.
The people who belonged to the
Gaelic League especially saw it
as something quote/unquote that came
to Ireland with Cromwell's dragoons.
What an awful legacy.
And, in fact, it took most of four
decades for traditional set dancing
to purge itself of this
strange, European historiography.
Indeed, the feile itself was
an acoustic lieu de memoire
of par excellence, thanks to the
great Robbie McMahon [phonetic],
a ballot maker who
immortalized it in song.
The feile down in Ennis in
1956 is still remembered today
as a rare Nirvana of
traditional song,
particularly because of
its initial excitement.
This was Clare's Woodstock,
if you will.
And even last year you see
here one of the two ceili bands
that traveled to Ireland from Japan.
Twenty ensembles like this
competing for the world title
of Irish ceili band music.
A six hour marathon.
Not for the weak of heart.
[ Laughter ]
And if you're in Ireland
again, as I say, in August,
you will probably get to
hear the Toyota ceili band
who won a standing
ovation from the crowd.
They did not win the
title, by the way,
but they certainly
changed the feile.
Ireland's traditional
soundscape experienced accelerated
commodification between the 1960s
until the Celtic Tiger
boom in the 1990s.
If this new departure was linked
to tourism, regional development,
and new professional opportunities,
it also fueled an increasing
excitement among young people
who for the first time choose
to learn traditional music
in formal educational settings.
Intercultural organization
of the music of Clare shifted
in the 1960s away from rural
kitchens and country settings
into formal school rooms.
Where we had a tradition of informal
classes, now the music became part
of the school curriculum.
In the same way as a
child going to school
in Ireland could learn Gaelic,
they also now had the opportunity
to learn traditional music.
One of the key architects
of this pedagogical revolution
was Frank Custy who began teaching
in the small hamlet
of Tulla in 1963.
In a sense, taught music to hundreds
of young people for
most of 50 years.
Many of his students, among them
Sharon Shannon and James [inaudible]
and went on to become superstars
of the Celtic music industry.
When the manufacturing industries
have come and gone from Clare,
tourism has long been its
economic and cultural elixir.
In the early 19th century,
steamboats transported day trippers
from Shannon down the river to
Kilrush and Kilkee from Limerick.
While Bianconi coaches made overland
trips for those willing to put
up with the discomfort of
bad roads and poor lodgings.
However, the completion from
Ennis to Limerick of the Railway
in 1859 brought new traffic
along the River Fergus valley.
And eventually, Clare's famous
railroad, the West Clare Railway --
it was always late, at least
according to Percy French --
in the 1880s finally opened
up access to the coast.
Victorian tourists, however, were
very different from the mass tourism
that developed in Clare
after World War II.
Victorian tourists were
aristocrats, professional families,
who frequented the seaside
resorts in Kilkee and Spanish Point
and Lahinch or indeed they
went to take the sulfur baths
in Lisdoonvarna at holiday in
expensive lodges and hotels
that were accessible only to
the rich and the well-endowed.
In contrast, the development
of Shannon
in the 1950s opens the
floodgates to cheap holidays
for returning immigrants, and
particularly Irish Americans,
many of whom made a
once-in-a-lifetime trip home,
particularly after seeing
John Wayne and Maureen O'Hara
in that famous movie in the 1950s.
If mass tourism created seasonal
and full-time jobs in the transport
and service industry, it
also fueled a huge surge
in the heritage industry.
So we began packaging
tradition and artifacts
from medieval castles
to folk villages.
And indeed, the people
who packaged Clare
for tourist consumption
walked a very fine line
between preserving the past
and embracing the future.
Yes, they capitalized on movie
and postcard images of Ireland
and they capitalized on
the marketing synergies
of airline and vacation companies.
And indeed by the 1970s
Clare tourism kicked
into high gear offering medieval
banquets, music festivals,
golfing holidays, river
cruises and luxury tours
through Clare's unspoiled heartland.
Positioning itself as a homely and
a pastoral antidote to the speed
and the stress of the 21st
century, Clare continues
to market its history, its cultural
capital and its exotic landscape.
Ironically, the products
and the vistas
that are packaged today are
largely the same as those
that first enticed Victorian
tourists to the region a century
and a half ago: the
Crescent Strand in Kilkee,
the Spa Wells in Lisdoonvarna,
the archaeological wonders
of the Byrne -- which you've seen
-- and of course Clare's icon,
the Cliffs of Moher, the latter
of which attracted a million
visitors a year during the height
of the Celtic Tiger boom.
Now not all cultural heritage
however fared as well as that
which was packaged for tourists.
Juxtapositioned with the
rise of industrial tourism
in Clare was an equally
precipitous decline
in the Irish language in the region.
In the early 19th century, most
of Clare was Irish-speaking.
Throughout the 18th century,
English was confined mainly
to colonial bureaucrats, the
courts, and the Protestant church.
It made progress outside of
the rural areas by the end
of the century as a result
of newspapers, commerce,
and indeed British soldiers
billeted in garrison towns.
The primary conduit of English in
19th century Clare and other parts
of Ireland were what we call the
national schools that were set
up throughout Ireland
thanks to Lord Stanley
who passed an educational
bill in the 1830s.
That's the same Lord
Stanley who many
of you hockey fans
appreciate so much.
[ Laughter ]
Designed to educate
quote/unquote good English children.
I'll say that again.
Designed to educate
good English children,
these national schools
became bedrocks
of education in most Irish villages.
They discouraged the use
of Irish in the classroom
and they had a tally stick which
child wore around his or her neck.
And the tally stick was designed
so that your parents were required
to put a little notch on the stick
every time you spoke Irish at home.
And when you showed up at school the
following day, you were punished.
Now this story was told
to me by this gentleman
when I was about my son's age.
And his name was Anraoi de Blaca.
He was one of the last of
the Gaelic speakers of Clare.
And tragically, in my lifetime, I've
lived through the actual decline
of the Gaelic language,
the oldest spoken language
in Western Europe, in
my particular region.
However, north and south of Clare,
Irish is still very much
a successful vernacular
and very much part of the
Irish cultural mainframe.
Clare's recent Irish-speaking past,
while inaccessible and invisible
to most tourists and non-natives,
had a very profound impact
on its music and folk life.
Clare musicians, people like Willie
Clancy, Chris Droni [phonetic],
were all first-generation
English language speakers.
They grew up in a bicultural world
shaped by a Gaelic past that endured
for centuries on modern
times that emerged
from the colonial ashes
of World War I.
Their speech, syntax, and their
wits reflected an older world
of poets and characters.
And their collective psyche really
sat uncomfortably beside the
progressive crust of
the 20th century.
Now new media and new
audiences reshaped Clare music
since Ireland joined the
European Economic Community,
which you know today
as the EU, in 1973.
Less preoccupied with jaded
notions of authenticity,
young audiences reshuffled older
definitions of Irish music,
moving it away in a sense from
its former ethnic moorings
into mainstream culture.
Countercultural and transcultural
elements were also scooped
up in this trajectory, particularly
in the village of Doolin,
which I'm sure many of you know.
In Clare, the village of
Doolin and the small town
of Milltown Mel Bay became nodal
points in this transformation.
Now 40 years later, Doolin is a
paradoxical musical sanctuary.
In a sense, it's a postmodern
simulacrum of its former self
where today the people who came
and settled I Doolin
radically outnumber the natives
of the village.
So the pilgrims now outnumber those
they came to worship and honor.
What's interesting is that Doolin
has become highly commodified,
as you can see, with the
confusion at the crossroads.
Whereas Milltown Mel Bay, on the
other hand, which is the site
of Ireland's largest summer
school has avoided the paradox
of its northern neighbors.
Now we're running a little short of
time, but I did have a clip from,
believe it or not,
Central China Television,
which is a multilingual television
service coming out of China.
A number of years ago,
they sent a team to record
at the Willie Clancy Summer School,
which was just finished, by the way.
It was on last week.
And what they were quite intrigued
by coming from China to experience
in Irish cultural revolution, they
were quite intrigued by the number
of non-Irish people
who came to participate
in this great gathering
of musicians.
And in the clip -- which we
won't have time for formally
but I'll be glad to show to you
on my smaller laptop at the end
of the talk -- they speak
with Russian dancers,
they speak with Malaysian
flute players,
they speak with Argentinian
pipers and Cuban pipers,
and hundreds of people from
all over the world who are now,
if I can use the expression,
prosthetically inducted
into the world of Irish music.
They are more Irish than the
Irish themselves in many respects.
We speak about the Normans who
came to Ireland in the 13th
and 14th centuries becoming more
Irish than the Irish themselves.
They stopped speaking French.
I love saying this in
Québec to my students.
[ Laughter ]
They stopped speaking French
so that they can know, learn,
and speak Irish and
become Gaelic poets.
And this is the kind
of transformation we've had
throughout late medieval Ireland.
And I think it's intriguing
that what's happening today
in the Irish world soundscape
is that throughout the world,
not just in the United States
or Canada, but in South America,
Southeast Asia, Eastern Europe,
Alaska, places along the edges
of Western civilization -- if
I can use that expression --
are now becoming inducted and
becoming excited about Irish music
and dance; and in fact becoming
master performers of that genre,
which is truly intriguing and very,
very complementary
to Irish performers.
The economic boom during the
Celtic Tiger years from 1995
until 2005 also transformed
Clare's soundscape.
And indeed, music became a
key element in the branding
and the commodification
of the region,
particularly by tourism
managers, bar owners,
and other culture entrepreneurs.
That a term we've become
very used to in our Ireland,
cultural entrepreneurship.
And music is a key
asset in that process.
A time of new trends,
creative alliances,
and conspicuous consumption.
Cultural production in the Celtic
Tiger years spawned a whole new
generation of Clare superstars
and Clare super groups.
People like Sharon Shannon,
Martin Hayes, and Maura O'Connell,
and indeed the Kilfenora ceili
band, who I like to describe
as the avant-garde ceili
band of Celtic Tiger Ireland.
They graduated from the village
hall to the national concert hall
and indeed the International
Folk Festival.
The [speaking Irish], the
Irish Music Association,
was also synergized during
these opportunistic times,
sometimes challenging
the onslaught of change
and indeed more times quite
powerless to alter its trajectory.
Internet sociology and indeed new
cultural flows also reconfigured
Clare music particularly
outside of Clare.
In the process, another
musical Clare emerged,
one that was virtual on vicarious.
If cultured tourism filled
the region with European
and American music tourists
in the 1970s and 1980s,
by the end of the century it was
not uncommon to meet young Asian,
particularly Japanese and Chinese
musicians, as well as Australians
and South Americans, all performing
music from Clare in Clare,
and bringing that music home
to their respective nations
and spreading the music quite
passionately among their own people.
As I said, they were passionate
about the region and its music.
These tourist performers,
vicarious Clare people of sorts,
galvanized their new identities
in sessions and in summer camps --
like Mad Week, which
is happening next week.
Please, if you're at all
interested come and enjoy.
Now indeed there are dedicated
communities of Clare musicians
in Paris, Buenos Aires, New York,
Tokyo, Washington, D.C. And indeed,
few have any ethnic connection
to the region, yet they continue
to redefine its soundscape
in absentia.
While global culture flows
continue to create new topographies
and new memories of Clare music,
they also mask deep crevices
of musical forgetting and amnesia.
And this, we're rather
reluctant to talk about in Clare,
not least the cultural
fallout from the loss
of the Irish language in the region.
While the region today basks in the
success and notoriety of its music,
it seldom takes stock of the
musical losses of the past,
not least the vast storehouse
of songs that disappeared
with the decline of the Irish
language, that once kept them alive.
While cultural nationalists still
regard Irish traditional music is a
sacred cow, a kind of lost Eden,
it is also an evolving ideoscape
where tensions between past and
present, remembering and forgetting,
nationalism and revisionism collide
and rebound through various spheres
of Irish cultural discourse.
In this sense, players' traditional
soundscape is no different
from any other soundscapes where
musicians are asked to preserve
as well as perform tradition while
at the same time carrying
it forward in time.
As mediators of tradition, musicians
are called upon to shape the destiny
of their heritage in the world
that is constantly
shifting beneath their feet.
I have little doubt that this
creative and symbiotic tension
between musical roots and
musical routes will continue
to impact the soundscape
of Clare as it will
in other traditional soundscapes
irrespective of where they are
in our ever-changing world.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now you didn't get an
opportunity to hear the music
from Central China Television,
so I thought I would leave you
with some of the music live.
The first short piece I'll
play for you is a [inaudible]
for the musical immigrants who
left Ireland during the centuries
since the Napoleonic wars.
It is particularly associated with
the western part of County Clare.
It's a tune called [speaking Irish].
And I'll follow with a very short
jig, which we know in County Clare
as the Green Fields of America.
The Green Fields of America
is a very popular theme both
in song and in dance music.
American musicians are quite
familiar with the real version.
I would leave you today with
the jig version reminding you
that this again speaks to that
universal theme of cultural flow
and musical engagement that
travels and has sustained itself
so successfully over the centuries.
So again [foreign language
spoken], thank you.
And thank you sincerely.
Might I mention, before closing, all
of the wonderful people who I've met
since arriving this morning.
And I would particularly
like to thank my friend Dr.
Nancy Gross [assumed spelling]
for her wonderful logistical
and professional coordination
of this event during the past
six months since I was invited.
And thank you all for
coming out this afternoon.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.